a question for you guys
um
is it easy answer but also a complicated
answer are men and women equal no no
no
men and women did you aunt did you say
no as well
i didn't vocalize but yeah they're not
equal explain why men and women are not
equal go ahead ally you want to go first
we're just not the same we're not the
same and if we're not the same then how
could we be equal so we can talk about
you know women being equal but i'm not
even sure that's a worthwhile
conversation because there's always
going to be somebody that has advantages
in different areas compared to
yourselves men are stronger and they're
bigger and they can run faster because i
don't know if you know this but strength
is it's sprinting is more about strength
like i can't sprint at all and then
there's things i'll beat your ass in a
race right now girl
right you know and uh so i can attest to
that because a lot of women think that
they're as strong as a man and that's
that's just not physically possible they
have so much more what about in the in
the workforce are men and women equal no
no there should not be professional
women cry in the bathrooms a lot i don't
think men do that my boss did
pearl you because you and ally both said
no immediately and then coco took a
second she thought about it but why why
do you say when men and women are not
equal i didn't think about it i just
didn't say it okay well i just men and
women are different we're not the same
we're biologically different like we're
just not yeah well our women are
chemically different every single day so
even like i i run a pretty successful
youtube channel i have a show similar
like similar to this setup in my living
room and i like bring people in and a
lot of my business decisions are run
through men and i think a lot of times
you're going to find like successful
women there's like a man behind them
helping them with the decisions because
like men are just more logical than
women because again we get our emotions
into it because we're chemically
different every single day but the
counter argument that i hear okay is
well you know men have been running the
world for years
and aren't all the wars started by men
that's not true
this is the counter argument that you
hear men start all the wars world war
one world war ii french revolution
america it's all men start in the
written genghis khan the mongols they
they do it all but they also built the
world boom
so they they allowed
they allowed us to enter the workforce
they had to tame the world so we could
enter it
like if we were still in like the old
days we would need someone to protect us
so you guys are not male haters
whatsoever your male appreciation no i
mean shout out to the men out there i
have i've built in the world i mean i
have five brothers so when girls say
things like men are trash men are the
problem
i'm like okay you can speak for yourself
like the men you pick are the problems
because i i have five really great
brothers i have a really great father
and so if you have an issue with men
like that's a you problem and don't put
that on me by the way that is very
powerful go ahead coco i want to add
just because he's a good brother doesn't
mean he's a good boyfriend
well yeah but that's on the girl to pick
you pick who you date like if you're
halfway a decent looking girl you have a
million options who you can date so i'm
not gonna when these girls come crying
to me because they hate all the boys
they they chose to date like that's your
own fault i mean i agree with that
whenever like i have this thing called
wobble cocodo every tuesday and friday
and i put a little question box and
people ask me questions
and they are sending me you know
screenshots and their issues and they're
explaining what this guy did but i'm
like you're letting this happen so let's
say you have a guy who only invites you
over for netflix and chill and you still
show up and then you're expecting him to
like put you on a pedestal and fly you
to paris or something but like you're
letting it happen and those are the same
girls that'll cry on tick tock and be
like oh boo hoo poor me and i'm like i
don't feel bad for you
i don't you picked him this must be
controversial with the women like you're
friends with you grow up with this is
not like are they like you're a woman
hater you're like but i'm a woman okay
i've picked bad guys before too i'm not
perfect but in every situation i've been
in i was like you know what that was my
own damn fault
usually is our fault yeah by the way
that is really hard to do whether in a
relationship or in the workforce look
yourself in the mirror and be like i
gotta own this l right here it's because
of my dad every time i try to be
emotional my dad is like your fault
your fault and he's right like i just
think your lot in life it's it's your
own fault and if you end up alone
because you can't pick men like that's
on you
agree agreed no objection by the way you
said that
took a second but you said that men and
women are not equal i just never i don't
like answering that question because
it's just like
i just don't like answering it okay
well they answered it
[Music]